in what many see the biggest step yet in
repairing strained relations between
turkey and saudi arabia crown prince
mohammed bin salman is set to visit
ankara
we will meet him in our presidential
palace and we are going to conduct
bilateral meetings and we will find a
chance to discuss how to improve turkish
and saudi relations to a higher level in
the upcoming future
relations between the two muslim
countries have been strained since
turkey supported popular movements
linked to muslim brotherhood after the
arab spring in 2011.
saudi arabia the united arab emirates
and egypt saw the movement as a threat
to the balance of power in the region
a blockade of major turkish ally qatar
by its gulf neighbors in 2017 further
pushed the two countries apart
but it was the killing of saudi
journalist jamal khashoggi in the
kingdom's consulate in istanbul in
october 2018 that firmly shut down their
ties
at the time erdogan said the order to
carry out the assassination came from
the highest level of saudi government
although he has never blamed the saudi
crown prince directly
turkey also launched a case against 26
audi suspects for their alleged
involvement in the killing saudi arabia
responded by boycott and turkish imports
putting pressure on turkey's economy
but early last year saudi arabia the
united arab emirates egypt and bahrain
lifted their embargo on qatar paving way
for ankara's reconciliation with the
gulf states over the past year ankar has
embarked on a diplomatic push to reset
relations with these regional countries
ankara and cairo have since held several
high-level meetings to restore relations
after more than seven years of strain
ties
in february president erdogan visited
the arab emirates for the first time in
nearly a decade while in march israeli
president isaac herzog came to turkey in
the highest level meeting in 14 years
signaling at all in relations after
years of turbulence
in april an istanbul court halted a
trial in absentia of 26 hourld suspects
and transferred the case to riyadh
paving the way for a meeting between the
turkish and saudi leaders the same month
erdogan flew to riyadh after months of
efforts to man ties
now in turkey with inflation exceeding
70 percent and an economy crisis just a
year before the election ankara hopes to
ease the economic pressure by signing a
currency swap deal with riyadh and
secure saudi investment in the country
in return facing increasing challenges
from iran and its proxies in the region
saudi arabia is seeking to acquire
turkeys by rectal drones which gained
international acclaim after their
widespread use in libya syria
nagono-karaba and now ukraine and saudi
crown prince's wizard will signal
whether these aspirations will be
achieved
al jazeera ankara